ce dubé bonjour dans le vieux la prairie
c'est vraiment très beau c'est joli puis
surtout que je peux vous dire que je
suis pas venu souvent dans la dernière
année et ça me rappelle de très très
bons souvenirs on va voir peut-être un
petit peu plus loin où j'avais eu
l'annoncé de ma candidature en novembre
en octobre 2018 suis vraiment très fier
de vous annoncer que le candidat de la
caq dans la prairie sera christian dubé
nous faut se remettre dans le contexte
était à la caisse
vous faisiez beaucoup d'argent vous
étiez un vice président ou au québec on
va dire ça comme ça je m'occupais des
investissements au québec
là vous tout va bien vous enfants
grandissent fait de l'argent qu'est-ce
qui a fait que j'ai dit georges gobet
j'avais une dette envers mon ancien chef
kim di bello j'ai besoin de toi ta job à
la caisse et fait long on a besoin
d'avoir un remplacement rapidement est
ce que tu es prêt à faire le saut il a
fallu que je convainque maquereau
jointes mais disons que c'était sur
l'opportunité que j'allais et la perte
financière parce qu'on l'a vu mr
physique est bonne cette année c'est dur
pour les gens d'affaires en politique
comment vous c'est quoi votre analyse
vous vous vous dites j'ai fait mon
argent j'ai pas besoin ou comment vous
êtes plus dégagé que d'autres comment ça
fonctionne je peux vous dire je veux le
dire je fais attention mes mots mais
j'en avais pas besoin d'argent non ok et
l'a donc vous passer de ça combien votre
venue à la fin à kavala vrai avec les
bonus le ça peut aller jusqu'à deux
millions deux millions là comme miné
sait combien sa soixante mille est-ce
que les mines et sont à ces pays
moi je pense pas mais je pense pas que
c'est c'est le gros enjeu en sport je
crois que les les députés ils sont pas
assez payés parce que déjà eu des huées
le rapport d'un madame dubé la juge dubé
qui a fait des ressources à bruz dans
mes muscles arrête je vais être
transparent la juge claire du béal avait
dit que les députés étaient pas assez
payé puis avec des ajustements à faire
ça c'est pas fait pour des raisons
politiques c'est malheureux parce que je
pense que rêve on compare ça au fédéral
les députés au québec travaille pas
moins que les députés ou fédéral y avait
vraiment un ajustement en faire mais
politiquement c'est une décision que
d'un peu suicidaire pour un gouvernement
d'ajuster les salaires des députés
donc vous le ferez pas à la carte moi je
pense pas que c'est le bon temps de le
faire le premier ministre avait dit que
on attendait que la situation s'améliore
bombay pipi fatigué benoît votre ami
qu'est ce qui est arrivé c'est quoi
votre analyse le y est il y aurait dû
être plus prudent on aurait dû être plus
prudent avec lui je veux charger mais
pierre c'est pierre on a chacun nos
personnalités
puis pierre c'est un des résultats puis
veut que les choses marchent betek des
fois ça y est à bousculer un petit peu
mais c'est lui et avec ses les qualités
des défauts qu'on appelle mais pour
attirer des gens d'affaires lui dit en
partant là il dit il faut qu'on change
le code d'éthique êtes d'accord avec
d'accord avec ça parce que garder leur
parler des sacrifices financiers que
j'ai fait moi il a fallu quand même que
je mette des actions dans une fiducie il
faut y croire
j'ai mis des actions ça me coûtait
l'argent mais de faire la fiducie pour
s'assurer que je trouvais la bonne
personne pour gérer ces fonds là mais
c'est compliqué alors maintenant si on
veut continuer d'attirer des gens comme
pierre des gens comme ça mais je pense
que des ajustements faire au code
d'éthique tout en respectant les règles
mais je pense que là on est avec des
règles des iob 1 30 ans qui aurait
besoin selon moi d'être les très jeunes
y est pas sinon des gens comme vous
comme bien fait ce buzz oublier ceux qui
viendront plaisent parce que ce que les
gens réalisent que je vous le dis il ya
des choses qui sont pros fait celle des
fois la ccl
je pense que les gens vont continuer de
venir mais on va peut-être perdre 5 à 10
bonnes personnes qui disent quand je
regarde ce qui est arrivé à pierre se
pose pas évident moi je peux vous dire
regardez le commun il ya eu des cris sur
mon salaire à laquelle avant que cache
quand je me suis présenté
il a fallu que je demande à ma conjointe
de dire d'un coutelas
bush tournée ferme les dents pendant
plusieurs semaines parce que c'était
assez agressifs ce qui se disait
il ya des gens qui pour d'autres raisons
vont dire moi je mettrais pas ma
conjointe de là dedans où je mettrai pas
mais les enfants là dedans c'est
difficile d'attirer les bonnes personnes
parler de votre conjointe il ya eu des
articles quand elle a été nommée au
conseil d'administration du panier bleus
ce qu'est ce que ça vous dit ça de la
politique mais regardez moi je pense
puisse faire attention que je deviens un
petit peu émotif ma conjointe a une
réputation extraordinaire dans son
domaine du marketing a été salué un peu
partout dans le monde pour les exploits
cas le fait pour le travail qu'elle le
fait quand on a la chance de dire
indépendamment c'est qu'ils ont rejoints
on peut tu respectes et les femmes entre
autres de dire si cette personne là
c'est la meilleure nation de même on
devrait être contente d'utiliser peut
apporter les la conjointe ou avec qui et
c'est comme ça que j'ai trouvé ça
excessivement insultant mais ça fait le
prix politique dont je vous parlais
tantôt c'est exactement bon exemple est
ce que vous est ce que au pire de votre
colère vingt dix bons mais jma avait
d'abord non non parce que je pense qu'on
a on savait que ça allait être difficile
mais c'est trop important de faire ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de faire je
particulièrement avec la santé en ce
moment même si ainsi des matins quand on
est un petit peu agressif de ce
commentaire le jeu le propos mais faut
prendre un petit vous faut pour
redevenir zen un peu bon je vois qu'on
retarde un petit peu le trafic
ces dix électeurs sur un faux je fasse
attention on va vous laisser pas assez
alors quand patrice quoi ce fait la
circulation
c'est bon ok c'est dubé pourquoi la cac
à l'origine c'est par amitié par pierre
fitzgibbon et par monsieur legault
ensuite pourquoi là vous auriez pu va
être votre profil est libéral en fait
moi j'ai toujours dit je t'ai pas
partisan je les gelées montré plusieurs
fois je pense que le sais françois
legault quand j'ai eu ce fameux cette
rencontre là en 2012 où j'arrivais de
l'europe puis j'avais vu comment si la
crise qu'est-ce qu'elle avait provoqué
en europe et je voyais ce qui est en
train d'arriver au québec à ce moment là
que l'on se souvient du printemps 2012
et cetera
moi je dis moi j'ai un gestionnaire de
fonds là où je vous dise fait 40 ans que
je me disais ça se peut pas que le
québec soit mal géré j'accepte pour ça
moi je te jure la chance vient d'une
famille à ses angles
j'ai eu la chance d'aller à l'université
on me donnait des cours de gestion
j'ai eu la chance d'en profiter pendant
40 ans je me disais ça pas de brossard
conçoit et quand j'ai rencontré françois
legault si ce qu'ils nous disaient on
peut faire mieux
le discours n'a pas changé depuis 10
heures on peut faire mieux puis on le
voit alors c'est ce qui m'a motivé à
rejoindre la carte vous auriez pu vous
retrouver chez liebherr ou dans un autre
mais jean vous dire qu'à ce moment là
toute la question
je peux revenir non mais sur la
commission charbonneau m'sick les types
pour moi non ceux ci a pas de compromis
souverainiste fédéraliste beaucoup plus
fédéraliste j'ai plus beau que non mais
beaucoup plus par ce que j'ai vu les
avantages du canada quand on est en
europe j'ai travaillé plusieurs années
en europe
pour moi être canadien c'est c'est tout
aussi important que d'être québécois
lorsque vous êtes dans un contexte
international
ce que j'ai aimé de la cacp et de la
proche de françois legault c'est d'être
capable de trouver ce nationalisme là
qui est pour moi
respectueux du fédéral entend comme moi
je t'ai aussi canadiens que je suis
québécois mais en même temps de donner
une priorité au québec comme le premier
ministre l'a montré dans les derniers
mois je pense très porteur que moi je
suis très à l'aise
est ce que c'est une question réglée
d'après vous la question nationale je
pense pas que c'est réglé mais je pense
que ça va rester en dormance encore un
certain temps si on est capable
d'améliorer nos conditions
on va aller à l'intérieur on va parler
de la santé quand même un peu moins
souvent l'idée d'un gros défi une bonne
idée ce tube et dans le pire de la crise
d'un gang est arrivé est-ce que vous
avez eue par de l'échappement
oui je suis arrivé à la fin juin gars
exactement un an où il y avait eu les
mains calme qui suivait la toute la
crise la première vague ça nous a donné
le temps de se préparer on avait fait
durant l'été le plan de la deuxième
vague
puis quand est arrivé le mois de
novembre
là j'étais vraiment inquiet parce que je
me disais nous sommes qu'on a tout fait
ce qui fallait faire de haut niveau des
contrôles des infections ne gérait pas
dans le détail vous savez on fait un
plan détaillé
mais le meilleur plat des fois peu
fonctionne pas là quand j'ai vu l'écho
qu'ils commençaient à monter j'ai eu
quelques mauvaises et puis ce qu'on
contrôle ça va bien c'est ce qu'on
contrôle pas kiki difficile j'ai
vraiment eu un moment très difficile
dans ces îles a séjourné
c'est ajouter après le délestage mais
moi je me souviens d'une entrevue que
j'ai fait avec vous à 6 à errer sur le
délestage que le chargeur soul est aussi
quelqu'un qui ne marche plus que besoin
de deux manches
c'est un cas urgent 60 ans et chanter
que vous ne il y en avait pas de réponse
magique donc j'ai été compris mais
regardez quand on fait de la politique
pour moi c'est la même chose que la
gestion faut faire des choix difficiles
quand on parlait de délestage on savait
qu'on rendait la situation difficile
pour des gens qui attendaient des
géologie mais on savait que si on
faisait poste délestage là on pouvait
pas servir nos patients coville qui
était la priorité du moment c'est un
choix difficile parce que ça veut pas
dire que la personne qui a peu apprécié
de chirurgie du prêt portant est ce qu'à
un moment donné par les 2 novembre
décembre vous disiez il faut être plus
sévère
il faut encore accentuer les mesures
sincères mais ça donne rien les
québécois nous suivrons peau plusieurs
fois qu'on a eu on a eu ce choix là je
vous dirai après les fêtes
rappelez vous après des fêtes c'est un
moment très difficile parce que on
comprenait qu'il fallait je veux dire
des confiné où donner
répit pour les gens pour les fêtes mais
on savait qu'on prenait un risque en
faisant ça pour le vus à vous avez vu
n'est qu'après les fêtes je me souviens
encore un matin j'étais chez moi j'ai vu
2800 là puis quand on donne un répit
c'est un peu comme je dirais avec des
ados des fois tu donnes un pouce puis
prenez un pub alors c'est ça qui est
arrivé durant le temps des fêtes on on a
des confiné puis il ya déjà qu' on a
peut être trop profité puis non on se
dit mon dieu on est allé trop loin
on est allé trop loin mais que vous avez
su en tout cas donné l'impression que
vous aviez le contrôle même quand vous
l'aviez pas way home mais au moins qu'on
faisait le maximum qu'il fallait faire
pour bien gérer la crise
ça c'est gérer les urgences les gérer
votre père était capitaine de bateau
bouge pas c'est quand dans une tempête a
pas de choix
ça c'est un bon mon père m'a toujours
dit puis comme il disait il y avait une
cinquième année forte mais être
capitaine dans une campagne il avait
essayé une chose à souvenirs c'est de
garder le bateau dans une direction peu
poète a contrario de la vague
une image qui m'a toujours marqué c'est
de garder en face puis n'oubliez ce qui
se passe à côté le look iran depuis que
cela sert s'envole au pis ça je me
souviens beaucoup mon père même ce qui
est décédé maintenant je le sentais là
dans ces moments là une centaine de
continuer mais c'est des réflexes
ouais le le vrai défi commence leur
armoire à moi mon sens qu'on a juste
fait on s'est prouvé qu'on était capable
je pense que s'il ya quelque chose
aujourd'hui je vous dirais que les
québécois se sont prouvé que madrid où
les petites erreurs sur le fil mais que
globalement comme comme peuple on a
réussi on est les meilleurs au monde en
ce moment le fou pour la preuve pour la
première dose la fosse félicité pis ce
taper sur l'épaule
on a bien réussi mais ça fait juste
commencé parce que là on a joué dans
l'urgence on a joué avec la vaccination
qui a très bien été
et la deuxième dose on est à 13 pour ça
moi ce que je veux c'est être capable
d'avoir au moins le même 80% 75 80 %
dans toutes les catégories d'âge pour la
deuxième dose
ça fait juste commencé là est ce que ça
vous fait peur le fait qu'il ya
tellement plus de corps que les gens qui
ont été une première qui sont allés se
faire vacciner une première fois se
disent boivent pas besoin de la deuxième
ça va bien moi ce que je dis aujourd'hui
là on est à la même place que l'été
passé on veut tous de passer un bel été
mais allons nous faire vacciner parce
que ça va être sa note armes contre une
vague possible au moins de moitié dans
le 18 30 ans m'inquiète parce que c'est
eux ou on n'a pas encore atteint le
pourcentage la première dose qu'on veut
on veut un minimum de 75%
ils sont à 65 % ça a l'air de rien mais
c'est quand même dans ce bloc lors de
ces deux cent mille personnes qui
devraient avoir la première dose pour
moi de travailler pour finir encore avec
ces gens là
puis on va dire on va essayer de les
rejoindre s'il faut aller vacciner
à l'extérieur du centre bell on va le
faire parce que ces gens là doivent nous
aider à avoir l'immunité collective sans
que cela vous inquiète pour vrai les 18
trous et puis je vais reparler encore
beaucoup dans les prochaines semaines
parce que premièrement fouquet chercher
leur première dose s'ils veulent avoir
leur deuxième dose puis de respecter le
huis si mal parce qu'il faut il faut
qu'il fasse maintenant pour que huit
semaines plus tard on peut leur donner
la deuxième dose puis qu'à ce moment là
on arrive en septembre avec les écoles
puissent être capables dans les
environnements conçoit jeu du béton mais
40 milliards par année ensemble des
normes
j'entends encore le premier ministe vous
dire you des fax est tout croche on sait
pas ce qui se passe comment ça se fait
qu'on est encore à l'âge de pierre il ya
eu deux une trâlée ministre avoue de la
santé qui ont annoncé des trolls et de
réformes qu'on dirait convient
je pensais qu'il serait bel et bien
toujours au même point de l'impression
les urgences accès aux médecins de
famille les années on a déjà des
problèmes structurels qu'on arrive du
mal à réguler et plusieurs raisons mais
je pense que l'une est liée à la
politique c'est il ya un manque de lits
manquent de pérennité à la direction du
ministère qui plus est les avoirs de
rangement dominice souvent plus vous
allez tributaire d'un mini scarifie qui
est sa propre recette et c'est là qu'il
faut garder les cadres selon moi qu'il
faut le garder l'équilibré en tant que
ministre amen puis versus la machine qui
a raison sur bien des points et c'est là
que que je pense qu'on est tributaire de
beaucoup beaucoup de changements pour
trouver la bonne recette qui fait que ça
fonctionne pas parce que vous avez fait
des promesses l'a4 l'urgence temps
d'attentes qui baisent sabé sport
médecin de famille encore 700 milles
québécois qui n'ont pas de médecin de
famille brahmi coûté que moi je vais
vous dire je suis là depuis un an j'ai
déjà eu la chance de faire 10 des
redressements des retournements des
transformations dans des délais assez co
l'important c'est d'aller chercher
l'appui du personnel cela dans toutes
les organisations où j'ai eu la chance
de le faire même dans des conditions
difficiles c'est d'aller chercher
l'appui du personnel ce qu'on a réussi à
faire dans la première année grâce à la
pandémie
je dis bien grâce à la pandémie c'est
d'amener tout le monde ensemble de
montrer que le réseau de la santé peut
bien performé sur des enjeux très pris
le dépistage le traçage et là les
québécois se disent mon dieu ils ont été
capables de changer la culture de la
santé regarder comment les gens dé
renouer avec le succès renouer avec le
succès d'avoir un service
la clientèle je dis pas que c'est
parfait l'homme il ya vraiment une
amélioration alors il est comment on
fait pour te rendre
il vous reçoit dans le quotidien mais il
faut le faire partout il faut le faire
dans les urgences il faut qu'un incendie
dans le prénom de ce qu'on a parlé de
journée par les sur de rattrapage des
chirurgies moi je ne comprends pas qu'on
ne suivent pas sur un téléphone
cellulaire ou son ordinateur où est
rendu son rendez vous comment ça se fait
qu'on oppose c'est facile la fin il faut
avoir la volonté
moi ce que j'appelle la main 5 6 gros
caillou d'aller à voir ce même succès
lors qu'on eut sur la vaccination des
capable d'être efficace dans les
chirurgies dans le soin à domicile
tout ce qu'on essaye de faire mais ça
passe par notre personnel est ce que ça
passe par des changements de structure
encore vous avez écarté samedi
moi je pense que les changements de
structures qu'ils avaient affaire qui
ont été faits qu'on n'a pas le temps de
rejouer dans des structures sauf où il
faut travailler c'est dans la
gouvernance de ces structures et la
gouvernance qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire entre le ministère pileuse
et le réseau c'est comment on parle à
nos pdg
tu peux pas le dire que montre ma
philosophie était clair depuis le début
de la pandémie l'heure je parle au pdg
deux trois quatre fois par semaine ça
c'est de la gouvernance et comment le
ministre parle à son ministère qui kills
pour faire les lits des stratégies puis
comment il parle au réseau pour
l'exécution de la stratégie
on n'a pas besoin de jouer dans les
structures audois je sais plus proches
du réseau salaires des médecins sur le
goût envoyé un avertissement la semaine
dernière comment vous abordez seules les
économies que vous aviez promis son pot
rendez-vous vérificatrice générale me
dis encore j'en ai tous là ce que faut
couper est-ce qu'il faut réduire le
salaire des médecins oui ou non
mais j'aimerais ça le diviser en deux
rapidement qu'est la fmsq pour les
spécialistes
on veut atteindre nos objectifs qu'on
s'était fixé en 2019 quand j'étais au
trésor avec nos omni il ya une question
d'âge attention mon boulot mais je dois
le dire simplement ces deux produits
t on travaille pas c'est bien écouter on
a besoin qu'ils soient soient plus
présents et de productivité ça me
travaille pas je dirais tu veux faire
attention à mes mots là mais je pense
qu'on doit regarder qu'on a assez de
médecins
on a assez denis puis je pense qu'on
doit réorganiser le travail qu'on soit
pu être qu'elles font passer dans
l'opinion passé de patients potentiels
parce que quand on dit qu'il ya des gens
le des médecins qui ont 5 600 patients
alors qu'ils devraient en avoir 1000
1200 ça veut pas dire qu'ils
travailleraient plus fort mais ça veut
dire qu'il y aurait une plus grande
responsabilité par rapport à l'or la
truffe je suis 100% d'accord avec mon
premier ministre on va trouver des
solutions
cet été cet été pour que ce soit
applicable en septembre c'est là dessus
qu'on veut pour rien moins de québécois
qui a pas de médecins aussi pour moi est
ce qu'on appelle la prise en charge mais
ça c'est le premier objectif puis le
deuxième objectif quand on a réglé la
prise en charge c'est d'être capable
d'avoir rendez vous dans trente six
heures parce qu'un québécois
c'est pas normal et candien bobo qu
elles s'apprennent deux trois semaines
avant même d'avoir le rendez-vous
tapadas lui donc la méthode bâton et la
carotte ni bâton
monsieur barrette vous voulez utiliser
le bâton ce coup y'a l'empêché de le
faire vous dites c'était pour que tous
mal d'avoir un bâton en réserve
il faut avoir le bateau en réserve mais
je pense que on a vu avec la pandémie
prenons avec les z'omni on a vu que la
télémédecine 6 qui était même pas
impensable le 4,5 à regarder comment ça
a été une bonne chose nous ont dit aux
ovnis vous voulez continuer à faire de
la télé médecine des québécois en
veulent et où l'arrangement est ce qu il
sur les honorables atelier médecin c'est
tous des choses qu'on n'avait pas avant
la pandémie
moi je pense ses solutions lors que vous
avez discuté avec eux dans les prochains
mois du fait du bien on vient on a
compris qu'il ya plusieurs défis devant
à la santé cet esprit de gestion vous
voulez allier ça se fait pas en deux
semaines
est-ce que nous engager à rester à la
santé le temps qu'il le faudra
de dire moi je la dernière mission
important dans ma vie ça va être ça que
je vois faire vraiment écouté le au coq
ma conjointe et cognition ce soir je
veux juste la rassurer moi je prends
soin une année à la fois pour être
honnête avec vous moi mon engagement le
site de servir les québécois
j'ai une passion pour ça mais en ce
moment je peux vous dire que j'aime
tellement ce qui est en train d'arriver
l'espèce de d'effet boule de neige qu'on
a créé avec le réseau qu'on ne crée avec
les québécois moi ça me passionne puis
taxe va pouvoir servir les québécois je
veux le faire
donc ce n'est pas décidé si vous vous
représentez un homme politique c'est
très long monsieur majewicz soudan il
m'avait demandé avant le 15 juin
non mais je peux même pas que j'allais à
la santé y en a j'entends bien mais si
jamais la cac
il reporte au pouvoir si vous vous
représentez pas ce qui va arriver c'est
vraiment un homme et les assauts
incessants visite tout alla il faut une
certaine permanence
oui pee wee le respect que j'ai eu aussi
cette envers ma famille une des raisons
pour laquelle j'étais encore capable
d'être passionné c'est que j'ai un îlot
avec ma famille qui est très fort quand
je suis là le week-end avec eux on
sentait des heures que je peux prendre
des appels mais les heures que je peux
aller faire du vélo en famille puis tout
ça alors c'est pour ça que je ne disais
pas la blague tout à l'heure si je
prends une décision continue et va
falloir j'ai une discussion avec ma
famille parce que c'est après la
politique on le vit là des gens qui
tombent après l'opinion des bears après
la politique
si la famille pas d'autres ont perdu
alors ce genre de show offert que je
discute avec un an pour voir la quantité
du jour c'est tout à faire
normal et bien une équipe west une
équipe qui sort du bus on vous souhaite
quand même cet été quelques moments de
répit en famille justement du vélo puis
on va suivre
on va suivre cette crise là qui est pas
finie mais comme on dit la vaccination
fait qu' il ya quand même le sport pas
mal et beaucoup d'espoir puis je pense
que si on continue de faire les bonnes
choses comme on le fait depuis un an
ça c'est impressionnant ce qu'on peut
faire avec la santé je pense les
québécois vont être fiers de leur réseau
de santé christian dubé merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur rolland